الامين العام لحف شمال الاطلسي اليوم
سنلتقي رئيس الجمهوريه التركيه
فخامه الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان وسيتوجه
ايضا الى مناطق الكوارث
وايضا وزير الدفاع هو يتواجد فيها كما
تعلمون هو المسؤول عن مدينه التنسيق
المساعدات والبحث والانقاذ في مدينه هاتاي
هو سيستقبل
الامين العام لحلف شمال الاطلسي هناك عدد
كبير من باقات المساعدات التي سيتم
تنظيمها في اطار
المساعدات الخيم وما شابه فيها وهو سيبحث
في هذه المنطقه عن كيفيه تسهيل نصب هذه
الخيم والمخيمات وايضا الحاويات السكنيه
وتطرقنا طبعا في هذا الاطار الى بعض في
الى الملفات ذات الاهتمام المشترك ومنها
كما تعلمون الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
تطرقنا الى عمليه استمرار عمليه نقل
الحبوب
وتامين محطه جبروتيا بالاضافه الى بعض
المستجدات الاخرى طبعا هي ليست
تطرقنا ايضا الى ملف انضمام السويد
وفنلندا الى حلف شمال الاطلسي رغم انه ليس
الملف ذات الاولويه الان ولكن تتطرقنا الى
هذا الملف ايضا في ظل هذه الكارثه بالطبع
تطرقنا الى ضروره التزام كلا دوله
بمذكره التفاهم التي تم التوقيع عليها
وبالاتفاقيه التي تم التوقيع له هناك شروط
كما تعلمون انك خطوات يجب ان تلتزم بها
السويد ومنها
خطوه الاستفزازات التي وجدناها كانت غير
نافعه ابدا ومع الاسف تسببت ربما توقف هذه
العمليه نحن من اكثر الدول التي تبادر
وتساهم في حلف شمال وتعمل على تعزيز القوه
في الشمال الاطلس لذلك نحن في تركيا
الحليف القوي وسنستمر بدعمنا الى
الى
فعاليات انشطه الامنيه كما تعلمون
انه من الخمس
في تعزيز القوه في حلف شمال الاطلسيم
ماديا وايضا ضمن فعالياتها
العسكريه والامنيه بهذه الكلمات اود ان
اشكر صديقي العزيز يعني
الكلمه له مشكورا
وجود
مالي الوزير صديقي العزيز مولود تشاوش اول
هذه السعاده لنراك مره اخرى واشكرك على
حسن الاستضافه هنا
واشكر
ما عليك على التعهد القوي الذي سيساهم في
قوه حلف شمال الاطلسي اليوم نحن نزور
تركيا نتواجد هنا من اجل تقديم رسائل
التضامن مع تركيا ومع سوريا
بسبب هذه الكارثه هذه اكبر كارثه تتعرض
اليها احد
الحلفاء هنا في حلف شمال الاطلسي نحن
نتقدم بتعازينا لكل من قضوا في هذه
الزلازل
ونتمنى الصبر لاهاليهم ونتمنى الشفاء
العاجل للجرحى
ونشكر كل الشجعان الذين بادروا بالتوجه
الى تركيا من اجل المشاركه في عمليه البحث
والانقاذ حلف شمال الاطلسي اليوم يتواجد
هنا من اجل تقديم رسائل التضامن
واليوم في هذا الاسبوع عفوا كنا قد
اوقفت لحظه
اجل
احترام وتبجيل الارواح التي قضت في هذه
الزلازل واحتراما وتضامنا مع تركيا
واليوم
نرى ان هناك الاف المساعدات التي وصلت الى
تركيا بالاضافه الى الاف موظفي عمليات
البحث والانقاذ الذين وصلوا الى تركيا الى
مناطق الزلازل الى المناطق المنكوبه
العاملين في مجال الطب رجال الاطفاء رجال
البحث والانقاذ المهندس انك عدد كبير من
الفرق التي وصلت الى هذه المناطق منذ
الاسبوع الماضي هناك من النرويج من
بريطانيا وايضا
من انا الوجه هناك عدد كبير من الطائرات
الحربيه التي ساعدت ايضا في اطار حامل كل
المساعدات الممكنه ونقلها الى تركيا
بالاضافه الى طائرات الشحن العسكريه التي
جاءت الى تركيا من اجل نقل المساعدات الى
هنا هناك بعض المساعدات ايضا الماليه التي
تستمر
بالوصول الى تركيا هناك ملايين اليرات
التي تم تحويلها وسيتم تحويلها ايضا الى
تركيا في اطار تضامن تضامن مع تركيا في ظل
هذه الكارثه طبعا الى جانب ذلك تحدثنا
وتطرقنا الى
[موسيقى]
التضامن السويدي والفندي في ظل انضمامهم
الى حشمت ولكن لانهم
ارسل رساله تضامن مع تركيا في ظل هذه
الكارثه وسيتم
ايضا
تقديم
المساعدات في اطار ارسال الحاويات السكنيه
المتنقله وايضا الخيم الى الاف المتضررين
من الزلازل وان جينا من هذه الزلازل كل
هذه المساعدات ستساعدهم
في الاستمرار
التخلص من هذه الاضرار هناك فرق تعمل كتفا
الى الكتف من اجل تقديم المساعدات الممكنه
واليوم انا سازور ساقوم بزياره ميدانيه
الى مناطق ازال ازال هذا هو ازور الفرقه
التي تعمل هناك بالاضافه الى انني ساقوم
بالنظر الى الاحتياجات اللوجستيه في
الميدان اليوم هو وقت التضامن نحن
ان نرى انه من الضروري الان الدعم
الحليف التركيه في هذه في ظل هذه الكارثه
سيكون هناك لقاء مع رئيس الجمهوريه
التركيه رجب طيب اردوغان ولكن كان هناك ما
قبل الزلزال احاديث عن امكانيه موافقه
تركيا لانضمام فنلندا دون السويد الى
السؤال الجوهري هل سيتم مواء الموافقه على
انضمام الدولتين على هذا الى شمال الاطلسي
ام سيكون الانضمام
الدولتين مع بعضهما البعض هل هناك موعد
نهائي او موعد للانضمام
الدول الى اجمل
يعني هل من الممكن ان
يشكل ذلك اي خلاف او مشكله ان لم توفق
تركيا على انضمام السويد الى حب الشمال
الاتلاسي تركيا تعارض كما تعرفون بسبب
الدعم الاسود الى الارهاب ولكن
ما عليكم اذا ذكرتم انا تركيا محقه في هذا
الاطار وعلينا ان ندعمها في مواجهه
الارهاب كيف سيتم التطرق الى هذه النقطه
في
هذا الاطار
وايضا
ان اسال معالي الوزيره هل هناك اي تطور في
بحث الملف ملف انضمام الى حلف شمال
لدينا موقف
متزن في هذا الملف او بالنظر الى هذا
الملف اسود وفنلندا
حان وقت الموافقه على طلب انضمامهما في
الحقيقه كل دولتين مهمه وخطوات فعاله
وملموسه في هذا الاطار خصوصا النظر الى
مذكره التفاهم التي تم التوقيع عليها من
قبل ثلاث دول منذ ان تم التوقي عليها في
مدريد خصوصا في اطار ازاله
عن رفع عن او رفع الحظر عن تسليم الاسلحه
وتصدير الاسلحه وايضا السويد تقوم
بالتغيير الدستور كما تعلمون وايضا
تحاول ايجاد اليه دائمه لدعم تركيا في
مواجهه
ومكافحه الارهاب وبالتالي انا ارى انه حان
وقت الموافقه على انضمام السويد وفنلندا
للانضمام الى حلف شمال الاطلسي ولكن
ارى انا مخاوف تركيا في مجال الارهاب
مشروعه للغايه الا احد يمكنه ان يتجاهل
هذه الحقيقه وهذه
النقطه وبالتالي المطالب مشروعه ومكافحه
الارهاب هي من اهم النقاط التي نتطرق
اليها ومن اهم المقاتله نلتزم بها
وبالتالي ماده الارهاب ماده مهمه في
اللوائح وقوانين حلف شمال الاطلسي
ولكن ايضا من جانبا اخر بالنسبه الى
انضمام السويد وفنلندا الى حلف شمال
التوصيل فهذا سيزيد من مكافحتنا للارهاب
ضمن الحلف بالنسبه الى سؤالكم عن انضمام
الموافقه على
قرار انضمام الدولتين هل سيتم الموافقه
عليها بشكل مشترك ام على بشكل فردي فانا
اود ان اقول انه بامكاننا بامكاننا ان
بامكاننا ان يتم الموافقه على
قرر انضمامهما ولكن ليست
الازمه هنا انضمام الدوله او عدم انضمام
الدوله الاخرى بل انضمامهما يعني ان كان
على حذاء وان كان بشكل منفصل او بشكل متصل
اما بالنسبه الى حرق المصحف الشريف في
السويد في ستوكه فهذا كان له التبعات
السلبيه جدا
اذا تابعنا واياكم مشاهدينا جزءا من هذا
المؤتمر الصحفي لوزير الخارجيه التركيه
مولود جوي جونغو وامين عام حلف النيتو